c'est dans la salle des fêtes à paris
ouest amoureux pas que s'est tenue la
première collecte de dons du sang
conventionnés avec le f s depuis le 30
juin 2020 la ville est désormais une
commune partenaire du don du sang ce qui
amène à quelques changements et facilite
une meilleure prise en charge des
donneurs nous mettons à disposition une
salle qui est qui est en accord avec les
besoins des deux le ffs est une mise à
disposition gracieuse bien évidemment et
en parallèle de sa charge à nous de
communiquer sur les dates sur le lieu
est de faire un peu de la publicité si
j'ose dire pour qu'il y ait un maximum
de
d'honneur qui viennent avant les
professionnels de l'établissement
français du sang était reçu dans un
camion et accueilli environ une
trentaine de donneurs ce jour-là 90
personnes sont venues faire un don ce
partenariat permet aussi à le fs de se
déplacer davantage sur le territoire
yvelinois c'est aussi la garantie de
pouvoir avoir des portes ouvertes et
pouvoir être là aussi fréquemment que la
population voudra bien tenir trois
autres dates de collecte sont déjà
prévues à maurepas pour l'année 2020
aussi qu'on trouve le jour faut qu'on
trouve le rite faut qu on habitue les
gens à venir et revenir parce que bien
sûr qui lui convient bien sûr qui à la
rentrée il ya eu l'été qu'il était
difficile mais en fait c'est tous les
jours dont on a besoin des produits
sanguins en ile-de-france 1700 dons sont
nécessaires chaque jour pour répondre
aux besoins des malades